well the White House and president Trump
have yet to comment on the deadly
Southern California mudslides nearly one
week after the disaster at least 20
people were killed in a storm and
mudflows last Tuesday four people are
still considered missing search crews
are now transitioning from rescue to
recovery mode Jamie yuccas is Montecito
northwest of Los Angeles where the main
highway through the area is still closed
this morning Jamie good morning good
morning take a look the 101 freeway is
still shut down it's covered in mud and
debris crews have been working around
the clock but there's no word on when
things will reopen here at the same time
this community is trying to heal
thousands of people came out Sunday
night to mourn the lives lost a
candlelight vigil filled the Santa
Barbara County Courthouse Grounds Sunday
night James Wymer came to remember his
grandparents Alice and James Mitchell
who celebrated James 89th birthday last
Sunday as the last time I saw them I
loved him so much cleanup and search
efforts are continuing around the clock
crews are focused on the difficult task
of finding the bodies of those still
missing
it was apocalyptic this is what David
Grogan Berger and his family saw early
Tuesday morning it was coming up the
stairs it blew out walls I looked and I
went we can't get in the car it's being
swept away by a five six foot wall of
mud and debris workers rescued the
family of three leading them through the
wreckage there was a reason that we're
still here and there's a reason that
house protected this officials say the
101 freeway acted as a catch basin for
massive amounts of mud and debris
preventing more extensive damage beyond
it they say they'll have a better idea
today when it can finally reopen under
normal flood conditions the Santa
Barbara area is protected by a series of
debris basins designed to catch excess
water and mud workers are now trying to
clear them out ahead of possibly more
rain this week but officials say no
drainage system could have handled last
week's mudslides it was a slurry with
rocks that are over your head
and entire trees this is a debris flow
of the lakes we have not seen
with the 101 freeway block the only way
to travel the 30 odd miles between
Ventura and Santa Barbara is to take a
250 mile detour now Amtrak is adding
some train cars to it Santa Barbara to
LA route and some people are hiring
boats to get back and forth by sea Gail
yes I know people are still stuck there
thank you very much 250 mile detour is a
big one Thank You Jamie